o único momento que eu acho que o
banheiro não é o melhor lugar da casa é
de madrugada porque tudo faz barulho meu
Deus tu tá caminhando de madrugada teu
osso do pé estala estar o diabo tu se
espanta contigo mesmo e de madrugada tu
faz de tudo para não fazer barulho nem
acende a luz porque tu sabe que aquele
negócio que tu vai acender a luz aqui ó
já incomoda a luz acende entra por baixo
da frecha da porta do quarto do teu pai
Ele já acorda então tu vai no escuro
mesmo porque tu sabe o móvel decorado da
tua casa tu vai só assim ó aqui é o sofá
né sofá então o banheiro é para cá vai
tranquilidade o problema é quando a mãe
arruma a casa e muda os móveis de lugar
e não te avisa pra esquerda e
v graça foi botar essa cadeira aqui pede
a Deus que ninguém tem escutado fica
aqui imóvel Ok tudo certo chega no
banheiro tu pensa que é só mijar
tranquilo sem fazer barulho Levanta a
tampa do vaso vai mijando aqui tranquilo
ó só nesse barulho aqui tranquilo ali é
um momento de Equilíbrio que tu tem que
ficar acordado o suficiente para mijar
mas não acordado o suficiente para
perder o sono entendeu então tu fica
meio assim ó tô mijando já já vou dormir
est mijando